ouverture
[Musique]
Californie
nous sommes à environ 2 300 pieds, donc les hautes
ressources du désert sont un endroit idéal pour la
production solaire. Freeman, toute la partie Fe
est que
la pénétration de l'énergie solaire est vraiment accélérée,
de sorte que lors d'une journée de printemps ensoleillée
comme celle que nous avons aujourd'hui, euh  le réseau pourrait
dépendre de l'énergie solaire à cette heure de la journée pour 50 à
60% de l'approvisionnement, donc le problème est
qu'un module comme celui-ci attire la course du
soleil au cours de la journée.
Nous avons beaucoup d'électricité ou
d'électrons sortant de ces
panneaux photovoltaïques directement dans  le milieu de la
journée et nous avons cette énorme demande d'
électricité juste au moment où le soleil se
couche, donc ce que nous avons est une abondance d'
électrons mais pas au bon moment de
la journée et l'une des solutions pour cela est
essentiellement d'avoir un certain stockage  à portée de main
allez-y et envoyez ça au groupe La
Solutions
2019 nous avions 250 mégawatts de
stockage d'énergie connecté au réseau électrique
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 5 000 mégawatts donc plus
de 20 fois plus en trois ans et
nous allons y aller  15 000 d'ici la fin
de cette décennie
merci étranger étranger
difficile d'entrer et de retirer la batterie,
retirez-la, cela nous prend 20 à 30 minutes.
Beaucoup de ces batteries auront encore
jusqu'à 80 pour cent de leur
capacité nominale lorsqu'elles seront  n'est plus utilisé à des
fins automobiles, nous pouvons toujours obtenir un
rendement très efficace de ces
batteries dans une application de stockage stationnaire,
il y a une différence de 50 ou plus, probablement
plus de 60 à 70 pour cent, euh, dans
le coût,
voici un
tableau de bord en temps réel d'armoire entièrement configuré et opérationnel.  Je veux vous montrer,
société de contrôle, que
nous avons les 1 300 batteries qui
fonctionnent sur ce site
en même temps, tout est
surveillé en temps réel jusqu'au
niveau des cellules et des modules sur chaque batterie,
ce sont toutes des batteries usagées, il y a donc
une capacité différente de chaque batterie.
puis nous connectons un contrôleur aux
batteries aux armoires et ce
contrôleur est l'endroit où nous avons la logique
qui nous permet de traduire dans la
langue de chaque batterie pour arriver à
environ 26 mégawattheures de stockage
en 10 ans, 20 ans, 30 ans.  nous
allons avoir des flux massifs de batteries en fin de vie
que nous devrons gérer
et le fait d'avoir une partie de
ces batteries dans une
application de réutilisation nous fera gagner 5 à 10 ans de plus, peut-être
même 15 ans avant qu'elles ne soient
recyclées.  Je pense que l'objectif
avec les batteries est d'avoir une sorte de
solution d'économie circulaire ici où
nous ne gaspillons rien, ce qui, je pense,
est la vision selon laquelle nous utilisons ces
batteries pour une seconde vie, puis
lorsqu'elles atteignent la fin de celle-ci,
elles  obtenir
des batteries recyclées
est
une solution, vous savez, c'est un
site de production complet et nous avons généré bien
plus d'un million de dollars de revenus sur
le site l'année dernière et c'est vraiment du
lait très rentable
[Musique]
étranger